hi i'm harold riegler producer at the
delic entertainment and today i'm happy
to reveal
some exciting details about our upcoming
game the lord of the rings
golem
gollum has always fascinated us while
being completely essential to the story
written by
j.r.r tolkien gollum's long chase for
his precious ring
has never been told in detail yet his
incredible journey
from mordor through mirkwood to the
minds of moriar
takes players to places they haven't
seen like this before
while setting the stage for events that
will ultimately decide
the fate of all of middle earth gollum
has pretty much traveled everywhere
he's also pretty much met everyone and
by looking at events from his angle
players will experience middle earth
through the eyes and twisted minds of
one of the most iconic characters of all
time
all of that in our very own artistic
style from his time in the slave pits of
the dark tower to his stay with the
elves of mirkwood
gollum will creep sneak and trick his
way past
faithful detailed environments some of
which have
never been seen before in such detail
the lord of the rings golem
is a cinematic stealth action adventure
it mixes stealth and parkour gameplay
and really leverages the delic's
expertise in crafting
engaging stories gollum is no
traditional hero
he's learned not to take any sides other
than his own
and some of the most powerful beings in
middle earth want him either captive
or dead in the game you will meet some
iconic characters
but also interesting personalities less
known to players
but nonetheless essential to the events
unfolding
we've been highly faithful to the
descriptions in the books
depicting for instance the moth of
sauron the lieutenant of baradur
who is constantly scheming on behalf of
his darkhole
in the game we will see his face for the
first time
but also threandwill king of the elves
of merkwood
father of legolas and last but not least
gandalf the wizard we're all super
excited to be working on this amazing
project
and we can't wait to show you more stay
tuned on social media
at golem game
you